-Well, hey, guys,
it is March, late March,
and that means that it's time
for people to --
Tariq, you okay?
Seem a little bothered.
-No, I'm good.
[ Scattered laughter ]
-You sure? You don't seem good.
-No, I'm just, you know,
thinking of some new entries
for my irk list.
-Irk list? What's an irk list?
-Come on, man. You know,
it's a list that I keep
of things that annoy me.
Random stuff.
You know what?
I'll just show you.
It's time for
"Tariq's Irk List"!
-♪ "Tariq's Irk List" ♪
♪ Of the things that irk Tariq ♪
-So, my daughter
woke me up last night
because she heard a noise
in her room.
I go, "What do you
want me to do?
You know I haven't been
eating meat, girl. I'm weak."
-[ Laughs ] What?
-So, she says she thinks
she heard a ghost.
Now, no disrespect to people who
believe in the supernatural --
I mean, I think I do.
I definitely believe energy
just transfers and never dies.
But I don't really buy into
the concept of the traditional,
mischievous, "boo," Scooby-Doo
variety of ghosts, Jimmy.
So, I go, "Child --"
I'm terrible with names.
I go --
-Your own child?
-Yeah, I --
-Your own --
-It leaves me.
I go, "Child,
there's no way ghosts exist."
And she's all,
"How do you know?"
which at this point, is pretty
much all she ever says to me.
I mean, she's 15 years old.
But it irks me that she demands
I produce proof to support
anything I ever said --
footnotes, bibliography,
complete this CAPTCHA screen,
identify all the fire hydrants,
stop lights, and bridges.
It's a bit much.
So I say, "You know what?
Somebody confirmed it
on YouTube."
And she goes, "Why didn't you
say that in the first place?"
And then I tell her,
"Because I'm kidding."
It's actually because I know
way too many vengeful,
spiteful, petty people
who've died
that would have come back a long
time ago to haunt somebody,
anybody if they could.
It takes one to know one, and
I'm that type of person, Jimmy.
I'm "petty" petty.
-You are petty?
-Can't help it.
I'm still mad at you
for something you said to me
on a random Tuesday morning
in 2009.
[ Light laughter ]
I never got over it.
I'm not gonna say
what it is right now,
but if I die
and come back as a ghost,
I'll for sure remind you of it,
maybe --
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait, I'm sorry --
So, you're going to haunt me?
-Yeah, maybe
for all of eternity.
So, I'm up now.
I can't get back to sleep.
That wakes up my wife.
Instinctively, she immediately
does something that irks me,
because for her not to do so
would be too much like right.
She says, "Babe, you're up?"
I go, "No.
I'm fast asleep, Michelle.
I'm sound asleep.
I'm in the Land of Nod
right now."
And she goes,
"It's 3:00 a.m. in the morning."
And that's like nails
on a chalkboard for me,
because the fact
that you said "a.m."
is already indicative
of it being in the morning.
We didn't need both.
It's one or the other.
So consider yourself irk-listed.
-Okay, alright, yeah, okay.
-I mean, at this point,
she basically has a high score.
Now I'm wide-awake.
I'm wide-awake, man.
I'm "woke" woke.
So I go, hey, I'm going to try
and get some work done.
And she's all,
"This is a personal problem.
You know, I could care less."
And it irks me
that we're cool as a society
with the saying,
"I could care less."
But we've unanimously agreed
that it means we actually
could not care less.
One could even
split the difference
and use the word couldn't,
but we just can't be bothered
with the business of adding
that one apostrophe "nt"
and making it official.
So, like, I'm a little angry,
just a little bit,
you know what I mean?
I'm not "angry" angry.
But I'm a little irked.
-Yeah.
-I jump in the shower.
You ever take
a irk shower, Jimmy?
-Have I ever --
Have I ever taken irked shower?
No, I --
-It's abrasive.
You could hurt yourself.
-Uh-huh.
So in my attempts to calm down,
I sing a song.
-Okay.
-And when I sing in the shower,
I go old-school.
I want some funky ad-libs.
I come from days when singers
would get fifty-eleven syllables
out of like a one-syllable word.
-Fifty-eleven?
-Yeah, yeah, but this new R&B,
man, they only got two ad-libs.
They go, "Yah. Ey.
Ey. Yah.
Yah-yah. Ey-ey."
It irks me. It irks me, man.
Back in the day,
those jokers would made "Yeah"
a 9-, 10-, 11-syllable word,
talkin' 'bout,
♪ Yea-ea-ea-ea-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-h ♪
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...that's flavor.
Like, we should bring back
words like that,
words like ♪ Wah-boh ♪
We need to add more flavor.
-Oh, yeah, I know "wah-boh."
-Yeah! Come on, more funkiness.
-Yeah. ♪ Wah-boh ♪
-You ever hear that song
"Get Off Your Ass and Jam"?
Well, first of all,
it was the profanity
that drew me in as a kid.
I was maybe 3 years old.
It was genius.
I'm not going to curse up here,
but I'll sing it
in pig Latin for you.
It goes, uh...
[Bleep]
"God am-day,
get off your ass and j--"
Well, there's no pig-Latin word
for ass.
-Yeah, okay, alright,
that didn't help at all.
That didn't help.
-But then they hit you
with that ♪ Wah-boh ♪
And, oh, man,
that's like the secret weapon.
That's the sauce, Jimmy.
So it makes it "funky" funky.
Man, you singing some funk
ad-libs in the shower,
and you can't stay mad.
So I get out happy,
and I reach for a towel,
but then I'm immediately pissed
right back off into irkdom.
The towel is non-absorbent.
What am I supposed to do
with a towel that just
relocates the wetness?
This towel,
it was giving me nothing.
So, I go,
"You got one job, towel!
The hell is your problem?
Stay thirsty, man!
Get your head in the game."
[ Laughter ]
"You know, when you were
a little wash cloth,
I thought you had promise.
I watched you grow
into a hand towel
and then a full-on bath towel.
But right now, right now,
you acting like
a little beach...towel
right now.
Actually, you're giving me
lettuce vibes, man."
That's what it was, Jimmy.
Like, the towel had a heft
comparable to that
of a wet leaf of lettuce.
So I'm basically trying
to dry off with a Caesar salad
before I decided, you know,
to just use
a bunch of paper towels.
Needless to say, the day started
on a bit of a sour note.
But right now, I'm great, man.
So thanks for asking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Tariq Trotter, everybody!
Thank goodness.
Better now.